- [Presenter] Let's talk a little bit
about selective incorporation.
You are already likely
familiar that the first
10 amendments of the
United States Constitution
are the Bill of Rights.
Bill of Rights.
And especially the first eight of these
are all about protecting
individuals rights.
So you have those rights.
But then there's a question.
To what degree are these rights protected
against state laws?
This became a little bit
clearer once the 14th Amendment
came along and just to remind ourselves
here's section one of the 14th Amendment.
We really want to zero is
on the due process clause,
which says, "nor shall any
state deprive any person
"of life, liberty, or property,
without due process of law."
Now, some have argued
for total incorporation
that says the 14th
Amendment's making it clear
that the state cannot
infringe on these rights.
But what has happened,
especially in the United
States Supreme Court,
is that on various decisions,
maybe this was something
involving the 5th Amendment,
they've ruled that the rights
described by that amendment
can't be limited by a state law.
So they would have
selectively incorporated
the 5th Amendment from the Bill of Rights
and decision on what the
state can and cannot do,
and their justification
there's a due process clause
of the 14th Amendment.
And to make that a
little bit more tangible
we can look at some
relatively recent cases.
In 2008 you have the case
District of Columbia versus Heller.
This is a really interesting
case around the 2nd Amendment.
The District of Columbia,
Washington, D.C.,
had a law that banned hand guns.
So one of the residents
challenges that hand gun ban
and it goes all the way to the
United States Supreme Court.
And in the decision on District
of Columbia versus Heller
the United States Supreme Court says that
the District of Columbia cannot pass a law
that violates Heller's 2nd Amendment right
because of the due process
clause of the 14th Amendment.
But that still left a
little bit of an opening.
You fast forward and in
2010 you have another
similar case go to the Supreme Court.
This is McDonald versus Chicago.
Chicago had a similar hand gun ban,
and McDonald was a resident of Chicago.
The government in
Chicago argued that okay,
the District of Columbia versus Heller
does not apply to us because
that was a federal district
and it would not apply to
something that is part of a state.
Well, the Supreme Court
disagreed with Chicago
and took the side of McDonald.
They selectively incorporated
using the 14th Amendment
as their justification.
They said look, the state cannot deprive
any person of their liberties.
So they selectively
incorporated the 2nd Amendment
into that decision and made it very clear
that a state cannot pass
a law that infringes
on people's 2nd Amendment rights.
So big picture, selective incorporation,
it's the doctrine where judicial decisions
incorporate rights from the Bill of Rights
to limit laws from
states that are perceived
to infringe on those rights,
and the justification comes
from the 14th Amendment.